merci
[Musique]
plus et plus vous gagnerez et
téléspectateurs le gagnerons sur twitter
hashtag tout de suite les pmp boiboite
donc voila vous partirez en week-end
avec moi tu as dit robin à 3,9
le téléspectateur et sa conjointe a
qu'un prochain exactement par à 4 voilà
alors attention et ça ça va être
l'horreur et syrie et sinon
frère frère proche aussi de techniciens
mais tu vois les gens font ça par
exemple au dessus de toi mon départ a
battu pour la quitter des bons joueurs
comme adama les autres ne maîtrise pas
ce que je crois stadion les techniciens
la droite pour moi territoire nous moi
c'est quelqu'un comme dadis par nos je
connais super bien petit pour ça dans le
coup
c'est pareil avec l'arrivée aujourd'hui
nous allons voir comment nous réchauffer
rapidement et efficacement est obligé de
faire un échauffement rapidement des
fous tâche monde est obligé de faire un
échauffement l'échauffement
l'échauffement
1 les changements articulaires 2
l'échauffement cardiovasculaires enfin
trois légèrement musculaire chez moi il
faut le voir dominer
elle revient en 2010 et devrait on dire
des sorts
regarde regarde hadopi on a vu pareil au
même
comment
fausses preuves je fais quoi là c'est
quoi l'amour
ap
[Musique]